[Música]
y
argentina es uno de los países que
llamaron a posponer la elección del
presidente del bid el banco
interamericano de desarrollo programada
para el 12 y 13 de septiembre próximos
quieren que tenga lugar después de las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu del 3
de noviembre en las que donald trump
busca su reelección por lo pronto eeuu y
otros 16 países rechazaron el pedido de
aplazar la elección en el vídeo y no
está claro que ocurrirá el argumento
argentino que conviene esperar a que
pase la pandemia de kobe 19 para poder
realizar la elección en forma presencial
aunque se especula con que la
expectativa del gobierno del país
sudamericano es que si logra posponer se
pierde cambie la posición de eeuu y
retire la candidatura del actual asesor
de la casa blanca para américa latina
mauricio claver carone es que argentina
insiste en que la presidencia del bid
debe quedar en manos de un
latinoamericano tal como ha sido
tradición desde la creación del
organismo multilateral hace 60 años
además el país sudamericano tiene un
funcionario muy cercano al presidente
alberto fernández subsecretario de
asuntos estratégicos
gustavo béliz como su propio candidato
para
[Música]
la fecha para la elección de la
presidencia del banco interamericano de
desarrollo se acerca de un lado 22 ex
jefes de gobierno y de estado así como
pesos pesados como argentina chile o
méxico piden que la votación se retrase
a marzo de 2021
de otro lado 17 países piden que se vote
de forma virtual el 12 y el 13 de
septiembre entre ellos colombia que
apuesta por fortalecer sus lazos con
eeuu esta semana en plena visita
bilateral a colombia del asesor de
seguridad nacional estadounidense robert
o brien y del jefe del comando sur
el almirante craig for air el presidente
iván duque en rueda de prensa mantuvo su
postura de mantener la fecha de elección
y volvió a dar apoyo al candidato
estadounidense
mauricio claver carone una elección que
rompería con 60 años de presidencias
latinoamericanas relevando precisamente
al colombiano luis alberto moreno que
concluirá su tercer período de cinco
años al frente del organismo
[Música]
la unión europea considera que la
elección del nuevo presidente del banco
iberoamericano de desarrollo debería
posponerse según una carta publicada por
la agencia de noticias reuters dirigida
a la ministra de exteriores española
arantxa gonzález la ya el alto
representante para la política exterior
y de seguridad común de la unión europea
habría pedido a los miembros del banco
que retrasen la decisión al menos hasta
marzo del año que viene
borrel alude a la inestabilidad causada
por la crisis del cobi 19 que dice ha
afectado a la profundidad del debate
sobre la cuestión pero también menciona
la decisión sin precedentes de eeuu
denominar a su propio candidato que
además es el favorito por el dice que
con este movimiento eeuu rompe un pacto
de caballeros mediante el cual el banco
siempre ha estado presidido por una
personalidad latinoamericana y en
washington no ha sentado nada bien esta
carta consideran que con ella la unión
europea se está inmiscuyendo en un
procedimiento interno de una institución
a la que no pertenece
[Música]